for a second i want to talk to the
people who are signed up for this
movement
but who i don't think would be signed up
for it if they really understood where
it was headed and
what is motivating it you know that's
not to say the anger in the street i
think the anger in the street is
legitimate but
the anger in the street is about the
fact that well-being
that productivity um was
captured by rent-seeking elites
and the fact is when you sign up for a
movement that's going to go after
ordinary people people of ordinary means
rather than go after the rent-seeking
elites who caused the problem
rather you know actually partner with
the rent-seeking elites who caused the
problem
and go after people of ordinary means
who didn't cause it and aren't guilty of
the thing that you're accusing them
you're just a sucker why would you do
this
why would you not recognize that
actually there is a huge majority of us
who would sign up for a movement
that was actually interested in draining
the swamp and actually interested
in going after the rent-seeking elites
who have captured both of our major
parties and are preventing us from
ever having any important influence on
policy that's who we should be going
after so what the hell are we doing
why are you being a sucker why would you
deliver the rest of us into the maw of
this beast
don't do it let's go after the people
who actually absorb the well-being that
belong to us
[Music]
you